[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle kevin je suis
gérant de des rires et les jeux une
boutique de jeux de société à montigny
et aujourd'hui je vais vous conseillez
quelques jours pour noël
[Musique]
pour la famille je vous conseille stella
donc c'est un jeu qui va se dérouler
dans l'univers de dixit qui va être un
peu plus tactique puisque dans ce jeu
vous allez devoir choisir des caftans en
fonction d'un thème et ensuite les
révéler aux autres dans un ordre qui
sera celui que vous aurez choisi
pourquoi cet ordre parce que il va
falloir trouver des cartes en commun
avec les autres pour gagner un maximum
de points
je vous propose sinon nicodemus qui se
joue extrêmement bien d'autres jeux
d'argent qui est prévu pour deux joueurs
qui est dans l'univers l'imaginarium et
qui va vous demander une petite gestion
de ressources mais aussi d'aller taper
sur votre adversaire quand il faut un
jeu qui est excellent très bien
équilibrée et avec lequel vous êtes sûr
de passer de bons moments
pour jouer en famille ou entre amis je
vous conseille mot malin un jeu qui est
simple efficace dans lequel vous allez
devoir faire deviner une coordonnée en
fonction d'un mot par exemple si je veux
faire dominer une coordonnée qui se
situe à la jonction entre ours et
docteur je vais dire vétérinaire et
j'espère que mes amis vont réussir à
comprendre
[Musique]
enfin je vous propose la course à la
présidence un jeu qui est plutôt
d'actualité puisque nous approchons des
présidentielles qui a été fait par ni
blinois et qui est plutôt sympathique
puisque c'est un jeu qui va vous
permettre de mettre des bâtons dans les
roues de votre adversaire d'essayer de
faire gagner votre partie en gagnant un
maximum de voix franchement il est très
sympa très facile à jouer même si vous
n'êtes pas féru de politique franchement
c'est un must